so i want to start with andrew tade um i
know you talked a little bit about on
your channel about the ban
um i have been very vocal that i've
disagreed with him on a number of things
in terms of the clips that i've seen
that have been cut and that are out
there online and i'll take some issue
with what he said here and they're not
all the time sometimes i agree with
something he said but a lot of times i
find myself disagreeing but i've been
very vocal that i don't believe that he
should be banned and that the recipe for
a functioning society is more
conversation not less so what do you
think though was there real motivation
for banning him because it's not going
to stop his comment from being in
december it's going to get worse right
so so talk about that a little bit well
i
i don't i don't know why they did it i
can't say why exactly but i just think
it's
weird it's a little strange how
a lot of men a lot of male kind of
content creators or men who are
advocates for men's rights when they
post on platforms like tick tock or
instagram they're often flagged like
there's a girl named just pearly things
that had a million million follower
account on tick tock just got banned
randomly she doesn't ever inside
yeah she doesn't incite for violence she
doesn't do anything wrong except for
point out biological and statistical
facts but she was banned on tick tock
while people can just be openly
misandrist on tick tock say
and literally call for violence against
men and nobody bad tonight so i don't i
don't know why exactly he got banned but
i just think it's a coincidence how
anybody who talks about male problems
and talk about things from a realistic
statistical and biological standpoint
tends to get banned and i think the same
thing happened with andrew tate he was
getting too powerful you can't talk
about biology in 2022 without it being a
problem you can't talk about facts you
can't talk about all everyone who's
grounded in some degree of fact now is
getting shamed for it or getting taken
down for it so
um i didn't know that about just pearly
things i know her uh youtube channel
i've watched some of her content but i
didn't know that about tick-tock that's
fascinating really really interesting
yeah so like it's it's just
there are literal calls for violence on
the view there are women talking about
cutting the man's penis off and throwing
it in the dish or the the garbage
disposal everybody's laughing nobody
bats an eye on wendy williams one of the
biggest shows in america she openly told
a married woman that she should steal
her or her husband seaman to impregnate
herself to trap him or something no they
weren't married they were dating and
they were they were engaged and she said
she said steal her husband seaman in
order to entrap him nobody bats an eye
but andrew tate goes on and says some of
the things that some of the things that
he says and he's banned so i just think
this is a coincidence this is one of
those things so what do you think the
effect is because i think that's true i
think there's a double standard about
who is allowed to have a voice
and who this when i say people in power
it depends on who that is it's media
companies it's some bureaucrats some
politicians sometimes big pharma gets
involved depending upon what you're
talking about
but
the effect of it is usually that the
person who's been banned gets a bigger
presence because all of those people
they've inspired or all those people
that have been drawn to them now feel
like they're under attack and say okay
we've gotta band together and we're
gonna just get his content out more and
more because they can't ban everybody
yeah so is that what you think's gonna
happen with tate yeah i think he's gonna
become more powerful he's going to have
to use a different strategy but it's
going to draw more kids to him and the
thing is what people don't understand is
the best part about open communication
is it allows you to go against dogma it
allows if somebody says something stupid
i can make a counterpoint to prove that
they're that person's stupid most people
can
see that that's stupid and they're gonna
judge based on what they believe is
right when you silence people
you you give them more like you said you
give them more power and not only that
when you try to make certain
conversations taboo
only people of both sides of the
extremes are going to have that
conversation now you know what i'm
saying so we're in a situation where
people who used to have power a lot of
power in the past
got we got this new thing called the
internet
and now they're trying to find a way to
keep that same power and it ain't gonna
happen because it's just too it it makes
access easier so uh you know and i think
the reason i could give like a maybe
a hypothetical reason for why this is
happening and it's because
misandry or empowering women in some
kind of way is is very profitable it's
very profitable like when you look at
feminism
maybe you want to go down some other
topics i don't want to know i want you
to talk i want i want it to be free
flying you know
i get going i actually start that's why
you're here yeah when you talk but when
you talk about like feminism and why
certain companies and brands may be
promoting it the most is because there's
money in it
women buy things women 65 of all
consumer debt is owned by women when you
look at who who benefits from telling
women that they should abandon family to
go into the workforce and that is more
empowering to full pants of the banana
republic who who benefits from that
companies now you have two two times the
people in the workforce therefore the
cost of labor goes down and you can tax
more people you get more money from
taxes so like who benefits from women
being at work all day and now they can't
cook because they have no time
mcdonald's because now we all have to go
out to eat people are getting fatter so
like when you look at who might be
responsible for some of these things you
have to look at who's benefiting from it
and there's a huge benefit and incentive
financial extensive especially for
platforms like instagram who openly sell
stuff to mostly women and there have
been studies about this that show that
women are two times more likely to buy
from social media advertisements so they
have an incentive a financial incentive
to cater to women to a certain audience
if you like the short clip you can catch
another one here or you can catch the
full episode right here
[Music]